Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
And yes my hair is still beautiful and red
And it will be for sometime
If you didn't see the last video and this is the first time you're seeing it then
Heeyy~ how you doing?
But anyway we're gonna find out if this game actually saved from the last time
Which I hope it DID
You better have you bitch!
If you didn't I will punch you in the gonads!
Like I said before, I'm very good at punching gonads
Wherever they may like to hide.
I will bash you down
Please (repeating)
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE! please?
YEEEEAH
That's my messy desktop
HEY!
MURDERS!!
COME KILL ME!!
Ok now we gotta be serious and now we gotta be very
Very careful about this shit
Ok so let me check my notes again
Ok so we got 3!
We got-- read 'em-- THREE!
I gotta crank up my audio so I can hear
The slightest, ittiest, bitiest things!
Cause I'm a paranoid motherfucker and I ain't ready to die
What time--
Baaaahhhhhh with the hacks!
Why do you always gotta try to hack me bruh?
Why can't we be friends?
People on the internet can be friends!
Oh DOS blocker
I better be good about this ok that way, that way
Ok this is easy!
Yeah it's easy! Middle mouse, speed up, I got it ok
I'M WAY TOO STRESSED ABOUT THAT ONE IN--
*whispers* Particular *Shaky breath*
Cause I know for a fact-
They want to kill me
GODDAMMIT THEY WANT TO KIILL ME!!
THEY WANNA KILL ME DEAD
Oh no not another one. Okay going
Down, oh boy
Down then left
Then up yeah whoo
Hooo man that one was going too quick too!
I'm not exactly ready for it
Helelelel
I just have so much at stake, I don't wanna lose it
Actually no I can't delete notes apparently
Butcher has nothing, weed post, zero day
Oooh
*Silent freakout*
Ok alright
We already got from zero day
Which is good
So
Hidden questions
There's a bunch of other ones
Eeeeeeeeeuuuueh
OOP
How am I supposed to know--
AHHH FUCKING COCK
WHAT DID I DO
FUCK YOU
GODDAMMIT WHAT I DO!!!??
What did I doooooo?
I didn't hear anything!
I wasn't talking!
Ughh ok I'm gonna get this
If I need to lookup a guide I will
But for right now I think I have a basic understanding of this
There's some websites that do not work at all
There's some websites that only work in the early evening
There's some websites that only work in the late evening
I just have to find out what they are
And I think I've been hammering the ones that obviously aren't
So I just need to find those
And also
I was recalling back and there was this slight whooshing noise
Maybe that was something I don't know
SHUT UP! ok here we go.
Ooop
Whoa
WHOA
what
*gasp*
WHOA
OH MY GOD
OOOOHHH
OH--OH MY GOD
Oh
It's a puzzle
Okay
*Mumbles* fuck ok
*Whispering* It's a puzzle It's a puzzle
*mumbles* what was it? yeah
*Gasp*
Fuck
*Music chord*
I DID THAT
WITH MY BRAIN
Oh my god
Let's go there
*Gasp*
Wait what?
It's the same thing
*Ding*
Oh that's right
*Typing*
Yes ok
I think it says "deep web wiki 2"
Which means that it's probably
More websites
And you need that-- that's why I could only ever find four
Which was a problem
Father Donald definitely doesn't have it
But that's ok
I've got my-- I've got my uhh
"Then I saw a great white throne..."
*Ominous music overlapping Father Donald*
"...From his presence Earth and sky went away"
FATHER DONALD
*Speech suddenly stops*
I'M NOT ON YOUR WEBSITE!!
"Then I saw a great white throne--"
STOOOOOOPPP
"And him who was.. and no place was found for them"
"And I saw the dead great and--"
Ok Father Donald thank you so much but shut the fuck up
I don't need you right now
Ok so this is good
Because
I have two
So I'm going to things
That I know
Have things
Like did this have a thing
Ok
So that was just at the bottom of the page
*Disembodied whispers*
What the fuck was that?
Oh god that was loud as shit
Ugh, I just went- I went to see if it was the same thing as it was before and it's not
Which means I gotta go through the whole god damn page
Unless I don't *Sigh* I don't know
See there's two trains of thoughts right now going through
It's either, random per page
But now that I found like
An entirely different area
I am thinking that maybe
*chair squeak*
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO
I'M BEING HACKED
[celebrity appearance: Ludvig von Ballencrusher]
*footsteps*
God fucking dammit. It-I got it cranked up so loud. I'm-I'm keen on every noise
Oh, not this
Oh God...
Huuuuuugh What is the name of the Pastor that wants to purge- Oh, Donald!
OH!
Minimum age for a hit, wasn't that 18?
I don't know! How would I know that?
I don't know that! Who the hell-
I don't know what the noises are.
Ok, so I have to come back to that once I know
More of the things
I don't know the things.... I don't know them
How would I know them?
How am I supposed to know anything?
So, I need to go to the Gatekeeper but, this is Deep Wiki two
This is Deep Wiki One. Which means I have a lot of things to do here.
Sss... so if I... go through... this... find all in, in-in Wiki One
And then go back... To the gate keeper
The gatekeeper is probably the last one
And you NEED to find that second wiki like you... *Ding*
*Typing*
to be able to get all of the websites you need-
*Soft laugh*
Bless your soul.
Woah
Oh?
Ah~
Oh!
Aah
Eeeeeee!
OK, ok we've been very bad.
Things have not been going good.
*Creepy mockingbird melody*
*Frantically waving five because he has five*
we've got fi-
ohhh my god we've got five
which is more than we've ever had
so I gotta hold on to this tight
Oh no
Ooh!
Ooh- ooh- ooh- ooh- ooh
*Whispers* I don't know
I don't know I've never been there before
NOOOO
*Grunt*
*mumbles* jesus christ
*Whispers* Jesus christ
(accented voice) "Where is the source? Are you sure it's here?"
Ok
So what I did there
Was
I- there was a symbol that appeared right here
I've never seen it before
*More frustration*
Mother humper
Jeezums
What was that?
*Ding*
Ok so
The gatekeeper-- the gatekeeper uhh
*Omninous whispers*
Uh *More whispers*
The gatekeeper has
Blood, blood. The gatekeeper has questions
I don't have the answer to because I've never seen the website
I have to look that up
*Hack noise*
Oh goddammit, fucking christ
NOT NOW
EEEEEEEGHHH ok kernel
Ok so I got a better guide
We're gonna do this
GODDAMMIT ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
Why now?! GODDAMMIT fuck this
*Ding*
Ok
OH NOOO
OH OH MY GOD I THOUGHT
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A HACK! I THOUGHT!
OH NO
OH YES
OHHH
I'VE NEVER BEEN NO HAPPY TO SEE
SOMETHING HORRIBLE
OH MY GOD!!!
AHHHHHH OHHH MY GOD
Oh man you guys don't know how stressful that was unless you've played this game
And then you know EXACTLY HOW STRESSFUL THAT WAS!
oh god
this is my reward?
hey friend
are you the guy who was walkin outside my window a whole bunch?
oh boy you're already-- ohhh
MADMAN: wakey wakey
uhhh
Prisoner: Where am I?
Ughh
Prisoner: what is this
what is this?
Madman: WELCOME LADIES AND GENTLEMEN! TO TONIGHT'S SHOW
WHERE YOU THE PLAYERS DECIDE THE ENTERTAINMENT FOR YOUR TWISTED VIEWING PLEASURE
oh oh no not buffering!
cmon! oh geesh
MADMAN: Now I'm not going to lie, this might hurt
well I'm glad they censored it with buffering
*drill sound and muffled screams*
AHHH!!!!
this isn't rewarding at all
Prisoner: Why are you doing this to me?
Madman: oh no no, I am not doing this to you
the game is doing this to you
Welcome~ To the game!
*music roll credits*
AAAAAAYYYY
AND THAT'S THE END YEAH
ALRIGHT OH MY GOD
YOU DON'T KNOW- I STOPPED TALKING THERE
I WAS SO PARANOID ABOUT LOSING, I JUST STOPPED FUCKIN TALKING!
THAT'S HOW PARANOID I WAS
The sense of paranoia NEVER went away
My god these thumping beats my bros~
Raise the roof!
I'm feeling.. fleek
Oh. My. God. I cannot tell you how stressful that was
like I-I-I-I'm honest when I say
I was stressed the entire time I was playing
there was never a time when I would be playing-- Like I did in every other horror game
where I would be like: OK I GET IT IM GONNA DIE
the stakes were so high
the stakes just kept getting raised the farther along *Small burp* you went.
excuse me. like it was just astronomical
how much stress was put on me
such that I wanted to win so badly!
I didn't wanna go through that again because it took FOREVER
IF I HADN'T FIGURED OUT HOW TO GET TO THAT GODDAMN SECOND PAGE
I NEVER WOULD'VE WON
I WOULD'VE BEEN FLOUNDERING AROUND FOREVER
THINKING THAT THE OTHER WEBPAGE WAS JUST A RED HERRING
Ohh~ man
But I did it. Uh, I had to look up a guide for the gatekeeper... Um
because it was asking questions that I didn't know the answers to
and I feel
I gotta turn this volume down instead of shouting over it.. omg
I feel like this game is meant to be
a collaborative effort
like it's supposed to be something that
A lot of people online and alot of people who are playing
are all working together at..
and because one person going at this would have a very tough time of knowing everything
but the idea that all these people-- over 4,000 people are trying to look in this red room
it's kind of reminiscent of everyone trying to play this actual game and get in there
so you'd-- you would think that they would be working together
and you'd think they would be talking to each other
and you'd think that they would be spreading information about how to get through this
horrible horrible place they call the deep web but either way
that was amazing
that was stressful-
but that was amazing
there are some a few nit picky things that I could say but I won't say, you guys probably already know about it
uh but just overall this was an amazing experience
I don't need to really reiterate any negatives about it
I had a great time and I hope you did too
so thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you~
IN THE NEXT VIDEO
BUH BYE!!